let's say we've got a rectangle
draw the rectangle
there's the rectangle
and we have two diagonals across the
rectangle that's one of them
and then we have the other diagonal and
this rectangle has a height of h
so that distance right there is h and it
has a width of w it has a width
of a w
what we're going to show in this video
is that all of these four triangles have
the same area now right when you look at
it it might be reasonably obvious that
this bottom triangle this bottom
triangle right here
that this bottom triangle right here
will have the same area as the top
triangle as this top kind of upside down
triangle that these two have the same
area that might be reasonably obvious
they have the same dimension for their
base this width and they have the same
height because this distance right here
this distance right here is exactly half
of the height of the rectangle they are
symmetric they are equal triangles they
have
the same proportions now it's probably
equally obvious that this triangle on
the left
that this triangle on the left has the
same area as this triangle on the right
right here
that's probably equally obvious what is
not obvious
is that these orange triangles have the
same area as these green blue triangles
and that's what we're going to show
right here so all we have to do is
really calculate the areas of the
different triangles so let's do the
orange triangles first before doing that
let's just remind ourselves what the
area of a triangle is
area of a triangle is equal to one-half
times the base of the triangle times the
height of the triangle that's just basic
geometry now with that said let's figure
out the area of the orange triangle the
area of the orange triangle it's going
to be one half
times the base so the base of the orange
triangle is this distance right here it
is w it is w so one half
times
w i'll do that in one half times w i
want to do that in a different color
in the color i wrote the w in one half
times w now what's the height here
what's this height
what's this distance well we already
talked about it it's exactly halfway up
the height of the rectangle so exactly
so times one half
times the height of the rectangle
times one half times the height of the
rectangle so what's that going to be
you have
one-half times one-half is one-fourth
times width times height so one-fourth
width times height so the area of that
triangle is one-fourth with height so is
that one same exact argument they have
equal area now what's the area of these
green or these green blue triangles well
once again area let me do this in a
green color
do this in the area is equal to one-half
base so these guys are turned on their
side the best base i can think of is
this distance right here
that distance right there if you look at
this triangle it's this distance right
here it is the height of the rectangle
so now we are dealing with the base in
this case is the height
of the rectangle don't want you to get
too confused the height is now going to
be what
the height of this triangle so these
triangles are turned on the side so what
is this distance right here
what is this distance well it is exactly
half of the width right we're going
exactly half of this distance right here
this point right here is exactly halfway
between these two sides and halfway
between those two sides so this distance
right here is one-half the width or the
height of these sideways triangles are
one-half of the width
so the height here is one-half
of the width little confusing the base
is equal to the height of the rectangle
the
height is equal to one-half of the width
but if you do the math here the area is
equal to one-half times one-half which
is one-fourth
height times width or you could just
write that as 1 4
with times height which is the exact
same area so the area here is 1 4
with times height area here is 1 4 with
times height which is exact which is the
exact same area as each of these orange
triangles and it makes sense because
each of them are exactly 1 4 the area of
the rectangle hopefully you enjoyed that